It was an Easter miracle. The state of
Palestine posted an inspiring message,
inspiring to jihadis, but also to
Christians about Jesus being an example
of the Palestinian experience. They said
on Easter, the story of Jesus born in
Bethlehem, living under occupation,
crucified by empire, echoes the
Palestinian experience, a people who
face oppression, loss, and injustice,
yet refuse to be erased. Just as
resurrection followed crucifixion,
Palestinians hold on to hope, dignity,
and resistance, believing that even from
the darkest tombs, life and freedom will
rise again. And they included this
painting of the Palestinian Jesus
wearing the kafia, a traditional Arab
head covering recently adopted by
Palestinian jihadis, but somehow
transported back in time to Jesus in
first century Israel. AP replied, "Jesus
called it Israel, and he wasn't an
Islamic, oh my goodness, why always with
the negative?" AP, why don't you knock
it off with them negative waves?
I prefer to focus on the positive. Look
at what the state of Palestine just
proclaimed. We've got Jesus born in
Bethlehem living under occupation, Roman
occupation since Israel was under Roman
control, crucified by empire, the Roman
Empire. But hey, wait a minute.
Crucified? Is that what the Quran says?
Let's find out. Here's surah 4:es 157 to
158 that they they here are a group of
Jews that they said in boast we killed
Christ Jesus the son of Mary the apostle
of God. Jews were apparently boasting
that they had killed the Christ the
Messiah. Pretty strange. But they killed
him not nor crucified him but so it was
made to appear to them. And those who
differ therein are full of doubts with
no certain knowledge, but only
conjecture to follow. For of assurityity
they killed him not. Nay, God raised him
up unto himself and God is exalted in
power wise. Based on this passage, most
Muslims believe that Jesus was never
crucified. They believe that Allah
miraculously disguised someone else to
make him look like Jesus and that this
other person was crucified in Jesus'
place while Jesus was taken safely to
Allah. But there's always been a
minority position among Muslims. The
minority position is that Jesus did die
by crucifixion and that the Quran is
simply saying that Jesus crucifixion was
part of Allah's plan and that Allah
raised Jesus from the dead. so that his
life wasn't really ended. In other
words, this group of Jews boasted,
"Haha, we crucified Jesus. This proves
he's not the
Messiah." But Allah raised him up, thus
vindicating him. So, they didn't really
get the victory over him. It seems that
the state of Palestine has adopted the
minority position. Let's read the post
one more time. On Easter, the story of
Jesus, born in Bethlehem, living under
occupation, crucified by empire, echoes
the Palestinian experience. A people who
face oppression, loss, and injustice,
yet refuse to be erased. Just as
resurrection followed
crucifixion, resurrection followed
crucifixion. Palestinians hold on to
hope, dignity, and resistance. believing
that even from the darkest tombs, life
and freedom will rise again. So Jesus
died, but his death was followed by his
resurrection. That is good to hear from
the state of Palestine because the
apostle Paul said in Romans 10:9, "If
you declare with your mouth, Jesus is
Lord and believe in your heart that God
raised him from the dead, you will be
saved." So, we have death, resurrection,
and deity. Have a little faith, baby.
Have a little faith. The state of
Palestine just granted two out of three.
And two out of three ain't bad. Now,
they just need to post Jesus is Lord.
Notice, too, they're calling him Jesus,
not Issa. They're celebrating Easter.
And they even shared an image of Jesus,
which means they reject the claim that
images are forbidden in
Islam. That's good to know. No more
complaining when we share images of
Muhammad. See, I picked a nice one for
our new friends in
Palestine. Of course, some of you may
think that the state of Palestine is
simply pandering to Christians in order
to win Christian support against Israel.
But do you really think they would put
politics over religion? Do you really
think they'd be so desperate for more
support that they would throw mainstream
Islam under the bus? Come on, be
realistic. They're not that desperate.
Besides, it's a very, very bad idea to
try to enlist Jesus to help you
violently subjugate your enemies. The
reason most Jews during the time of
Jesus rejected him was that they
expected the Messiah to destroy their
enemies, the Romans. He didn't destroy
their enemies, so they rejected him.
Later, at his Roman trial, Pilate asked
Jesus about being the king of the Jews.
John
18:36, Jesus answered, "My kingdom is
not of this world. If my kingdom were of
this world, my servants would be
fighting so that I would not be handed
over to the Jews. But as it is, my
kingdom is not of this realm. His
servants weren't fighting the Jewish
leaders because his kingdom wasn't and
still isn't an earthly kingdom. He
didn't come to fight the Romans. He
didn't come to fight the Jews.
And so we know that the state of
Palestine definitely isn't trying to
enlist Jesus and his followers to help
them violently subjugate people. Now, we
can only conclude that their Easter post
about Jesus was a heartfelt endorsement
of the Christian message that Jesus died
on the cross and rose from the dead. And
now we just need to hear them declare
that Jesus Christ is Lord. Because
accepting the gospel and realizing that
the kingdom of God is not an earthly
kingdom will finally end the endless
battle for land and power. And that will
truly be life from death. Easter in
action.
If you'd like to understand why the
state of Palestine may actually be right
when they affirm the minority Islamic
position about the Quran, be sure to
watch my video, The Quran doesn't say
what Muslims think it says.
[Music]